on top of the yonko and the Admirals the
One Piece manga just revealed a whole
new group of incredibly powerful
Fighters called The Holy nights that
might end up becoming the most powerful
group of fighters in the entire story
and the final enemies of the straw hats
in their battle against emu and you
won't believe all the crazy secrets
about the identities of these mysterious
Fighters that are being said lose to
destroy the world plus we finally
learned what happened during the reverie
and we also see the true powers of the
Revolutionary Army revealed in a battle
so destructive it could have destroyed
an entire Island but of course we first
have to start with these holy nights now
this group was actually first name
dropped in chapter 1054 when Akino
revealed that the holy nights are
responsible for resolving disputes
within the holy lands okay but that
could be a lot so does that mean that
they work for the celestial dragons or
can they even hand out Justice to the
world Nobles themselves I mean either
way they must be pretty damn important
not to mention super powerful to become
the world government's Ultimate Warriors
and of course if you're wondering if
they're even stronger than the Admirals
well stick around because we'll be
discussing that in just a moment but
also are you ever blown away by how deep
and detailed the world and history of
One Piece truly is I mean if you enjoy
talking and learning about pirate
history you will definitely love doing
so with actual history as well with the
help of today's sponsored historic now
the idea behind historic male is pretty
unique I think it's part of this really
creative novelty gift you will be sent
an envelope delivered to your doorstep
every
crafted reproductions of a letter
written by an important historical
figure and that as if they were
accidentally sent to you including of
course explanation and context for
example this is a letter from Walt
Disney address to Richard Nixon or this
one from Franklin Roosevelt to Winston
Churchill or my favorite one right here
where Churchill wrote to his wife
including a really cute drawing of this
puck in short historic mail is the
perfect gift for history lovers where
you can learn about the most interesting
parts of History by the people who
actually lived it through their very own
thoughts now usually historic mail
offers 10 weekly letters for only 59.99
but this Mother's Day you can surprise
your mom with this Timeless gift by
enjoying 10 off on all their products
with the Mother's Day sale all you have
to do is go to historicmail.com Ohara to
get your gifts now and help support this
Channel and now back to the video first
in this chapter we get this panel here
offset holy nights as Dragon says that
with the whole holy nights making their
move the real battle starts for the
Revolutionary Army as well now we are
learning in this chapter that these nine
Knights are actually being sent out to
literally destroy kingdoms that are
currently rebelling against the world
governments and in case you're wondering
these eight kingdoms actually decided to
break off when they found out about what
happened to this Kingdom that you might
remember was destroyed by this insane
light attack in chapter 1060. though
I'll say the fact that these kingdoms
even know this information in the first
place makes me wonder how they could
have learned about the Kingdom's
destruction in the first place I mean
did Sabo leak the information or did the
world find out some other way anyway
back to the holy nights these nine
insane Fighters are tasked with dealing
with these Rebel kingdoms and we have to
assume the worst here honestly these
kingdoms are probably going to be wiped
out entirely or at least the rulers will
be killed and replaced and that of
course gives us a true hint of how
strong these Knights must really be
since there are nine Knights and age
Rebel kingdoms I'm wondering if each
Knight will take out one Kingdom or if
they will work as a group together and
go from one to the next but personally I
think that if these Knights are actually
as powerful as we hope they are then
surely they'd be able to take out a
normal country on their own I mean
sanji's Brothers basically took out an
entire Kingdom themselves with just the
help of some clone so I do like to think
that the holy nights have to at least be
that strong and since sanji's brothers
were also able to take out some of big
man's strongest children that puts these
Knights at least on the level of a yonko
commander at least and if they're
actually meant to later match up with
the straw hats then they better be at
least this strong or they won't stand a
chance because I think it would be truly
disappointing if Oda introduced these
nine unknown Ultra powerful characters
this late in the story that then would
just end up kind of like kaido's Toby
Ropo who in the end didn't make that
much of an impact in the story however
looking at from the other side could
they be even and stronger I mean since
dragons seems to see these nine as the
ultimate force of the world governments
there's a pretty good chance that these
might be even stronger than yes the
Admirals but you know when you think
about it might make sense given that
many of the strongest Marines including
the lights of aokiji and the Cairo
himself don't really like doing the
Dirty Work of the world nobled so if
many of the Marines actually flipped
sides to join Luffy during the final
battle having not only the seraphim but
a whole new group of god-like Warriors
that fight for emu and the world Nobles
that would make a whole lot of sense I
think but now let's put on our Theory
hats because from the images that we got
in this chapter plus other clues that we
can pull from the actual storyline I
think we can paint a pretty decent
picture of who these insanely strong
Knights could actually be starting
obviously with this one right here who
could very well be shanks's long-lost
brother or father I mean just the
Silhouettes here alone has a lot of
striking similarities such as a similar
body type clothing and even a similar
sort so unless these Knights are
actually shapeshifters then this guy is
probably somehow related to the
red-haired Emperor and before you guys
go crazy in the comments just remember
that Shanks is actually from the figure
land family which as we explained in my
complete story of Shanks video means
that he was most likely a Celestial
Dragon that got then separated from his
family so what if the figureland family
had another son maybe even a twin who
became one of the Holy nights or another
Super interesting idea here is that what
if the holy nights all are from the
figureland family kind of like a single
overpowered family who protected the
celestial dragons though wait there is
even more mind-blowing evidence for this
idea and it comes from chapter 907 and
that is the very famous scene of shang's
meeting with the five Elders so hear me
out here for a second what if this
wasn't actually actually Shanks but
instead it was his identical brother and
damn this would go a long way towards
explaining one of the most controversial
and mysterious scenes in the entire
story do I even need to tell you how
many crazy videos were spawned from this
one scene Shanks is evil the history of
evil Shanks Shanks is using Luffy
honestly this scene broke the fanbase
and we have yet to get a real
explanation for it we never knew how
Shanks got in or why the gorosei would
agree to meet him in the first place but
now it is entirely possible that Oda was
just toying with us all this time
because it wasn't even Shanks but his
brothers father slash twin whatever he
wants and I mean in this scene we never
actually hear the elders call this
person by a name and we never see the
SCAR or the missing arm and if this was
a holy night it would make sense that
the gorosei would agreed to meet with
them but that is not even the end of the
evidence because in an interview with
Japanese TV that my friend Archer from
the library of O'Hara translated on his
website the author of One Piece was
actually asked if chengs is actually two
different people yeah someone asked him
that and this was asked with the
contacts that Shang seems to be able to
move very quickly around the world like
when he stabbed kaido from coming to
Marine Forge and then only shortly after
showing up at the war himself with his
crew and it does look like Ola Sensei
actually answered the question but it
was censored from the show so that could
mean that this theory is entirely
possible I mean if it wasn't true
wouldn't he just have come out and said
no I mean no harm with that right but
with all the incredible speculation
about this shank's looking knight what
about all the other holy nights well we
can see that one of them here wears some
sort of hat cowboy hat maybe or like a
big one and this one here seems to have
horns so what if the holy nights are
actually somehow related to the other
yonko such as kaido and big mom I mean
kaido certainly has horns and big mom
used to wear a similar looking hat to
this one however of course they can't
all be related like Shanks and his
potential twin but now that makes me
wonder if there might be actually clones
of other strong Pirates and I mean with
everything going on on echid Islands
cloning is certainly a possibility that
was around over 20 years ago but at this
point we've thrown out three Emperors of
the sea as possible members of these
holy nights but now let's raise the
stakes even higher because what would
you say if I told you that some of the
most legendary figures from the past
such as Joy boy himself were a part of
the Holy nights don't believe me better
keep watching okay so in chapter 906 we
first meet this mysterious cloaked
figure emu who we later learn is the
secret ruler of the entire world and
after they climb this ridiculously large
staircase they arrive at some sort of
secret chamber that is ice cold here we
see the famous image of his Frozen straw
hats which has led to an even greater
host of theories about Joey Boy and this
mysterious King but one possibility that
I want to throw out here is that this
freezer is actually where the holy
Nights Live and that some of them are
the preserved fighters from the ancient
past now there are a few pieces of
evidence to support this idea such as
the zombie fighters from thrillerbaric
being frozen to preserve their bodies as
well plus emu is ascending these massive
stairs almost like they're ascending
into heaven to reach the holy nights but
the most compelling piece of evidence is
this image right here directly above the
Frozen straw hat is this image of a
cross-looking symbol now what exactly
the symbol is we don't exactly know yet
but it is very similar to that of the
world government cross and a famous
symbol of the Knights Templar which of
course we will also be discussing in
more detail in just a few minutes and if
this is actually a symbol that
represents the holy nights then that
would mean that each of these little
alcohols in this freezer could be the
resting place of one of these nights
alright but that was a lot of wild
speculation admittedly from just this
little detail well man it's just too
much fun and part of the reason that we
read one piece in the first place right
however we are not quite done with the
Holy nights yet because there are even
more connections to famous characters in
the story for example mihawk could well
be a former Holy Knight himself I mean
he's always had a heavy Christian
religious theme going on and someone on
Twitter pointed out his markings on his
famous giant sword yoru are actually
kinda similar to the markings on emu's
empty throne and of course he has the
same ring-shaped eyes and we have no
idea what his origin story is or how he
even became the strongest swordsman in
one piece in the first place the former
warlord Bartholomew Kuma is another
character with ties to Christian
religion since he used to carry around
his giant Bible so was he a Holy Knight
in the past as well did she go around
smacking the gospel into enemies of the
world governments then there's of course
also the idea that the holy Knights
could be descendants of the lunarians
the race that used to live on top of the
grand line who were called Gods but
there is not really that much evidence
for that right now especially since we
were just introduced to the seraphim who
are also all based on lunarians but
moving on it is now time to throw on
your history hat on top of your theory
hat because we're going to do a short
detour down everyone's favorite Rabbit
Hole religious symbolism in one piece
and that's because the first thing that
I thought when I heard about these holy
nights was the legendary Knights Templar
and probably you too which was of course
also inspiration for the thumbnail that
I think turned out pretty nicely now
this was a famous group of religious
Warriors who fought for Christianity in
the Holy Land which was Jerusalem in
medieval Europe and there are a few
truly interesting connections between
the night Templar and the holy nights
first off the Templars were supposedly
founded by nine original members which
included Warriors as well as monks which
makes me wonder if we could see some
non-fighters with the Holy nights as
well on top of that in the Bible the
number nine symbolizes divine
completeness or conveys the meaning of
finality there are also the obvious
similarities between the templar's Red
Cross symbol and the world government's
cross so basically what I'm reading into
all of this is that the world government
is really some massive cult that took
over the world oh no Luffy please save
us all and on top of all that the
Tempest Duty was to protect Travelers
visiting the holy lands but that's a
little bit twisted in the story because
now these holy nights are protecting
these so-called Gods but the Templars
themselves aren't the only major symbol
related to these nine holy nights and we
might actually be able to figure out
some more about the knights just based
on the number nine itself first there
are nine real pony glyphs which
supposedly tell the true history of the
world so could these Knights be somehow
related to the true history Plus in
Japanese culture nine is actually
sometimes considered to be an unlucky
number because it contains the character
coup which means pain or suffering you
might be familiar with the entire you
know wordplay thing from the big Theory
video I made so maybe the knights are in
constant pain pain or are meant to
protect the gods from pain or are pain
themselves and in the past nine was also
a number associated with the Japanese
emperor who was considered to be divine
basically a God so for a while it was
actually considered taboo for normal
people to use the number nine which now
actually brings us all the way to
Buddhism which also has strong ties to
the number nine that might actually tell
us a bit more about the powers or
personalities of these nine holy nights
for one in Buddhism there are the nine
holy qualities of the Buddha sharing
ethical morality patience renunciation
wisdom diligence truthfulness
determination loving kindness and
Equanimity now these nine could all be
hints about the knight's characters and
another branch of their faith has
something called the nine
consciousnesses of Buddhism which are
basically nine states of being and
awareness now the first five states are
basically the five senses touch taste
sight smell and hearing the sixth one
involves your brain processing these
Senses Into meaning meaningful
information the seventh state involves
becoming aware of one's inner thoughts
the eighth state is sometimes called a
storehouse containing all of a person's
thoughts words feelings and deeds
throughout their lifetime and actually
this state is also said to persist even
after death so Brooks match up anyone
and finally the ninth final stage is
basically the Buddha state is when
someone rids themselves of all the
negative Karma and one Soul can finally
coexist peacefully with all other life
forms okay um there is a lot to unpack
here but maybe I'll make a future video
comparing the straw hats to each one of
the nine states to see if we can figure
out who they match up against in a
future battle so make sure to subscribe
to the channel if you don't want to miss
that okay but now that we've spent way
too much time breaking down this new
exciting group of Fighters there is a
lot that has happened in this chapter
that's also worth talking about so let's
discuss everything else that happened
and how it will completely change the
one piece world forever so during the
flashback at the reverie we see Cobra
the king of alabaster about to meet with
the five elders and now at this point we
do know that Cobra was assassinated by
someone and that Luffy's brother Sabo
was framed for killing this King and
before he goes into this meeting Cobra
tells his guards that they should take
care of his daughter Vivi and now why
would he say this well the obvious
answer is that he was expecting to not
come out of this room alive which is
exactly what happened but let's actually
back up a little bit because I think the
reason that Cobra went to talk to the
Goro says in the first place was because
government agents had already captured
Vivi now why did they capture Vivi well
back in chapter 908 we see emu holding a
picture of Vivi and then the elders
asking who emu would like to have erased
from history so basically they did want
to have VV taken out for some reason but
now back to COBRA he probably knew that
his daughter had been taken and so he
goes to confront the elders which of
course would lead to his eventual death
however that is not the end-all be-all
to this because later we see Sabo
reacting to Cobra's death as well well
now this is presumably when the picture
to frame Saba was taken but as we know
Sabo was probably able to rescue Vivi at
some point as well as she is now with
Morgans but I'm also wondering if the
gorosei had another reason for killing
Cobra I mean he wasn't their original
Target so unless it was an accident
there has to be better some other reason
that they killed him because killing a
king would throw the world into even
more chaos but really the only reason
that I can think of is that Cobra knows
something about the void Century
anti-forbidden history and he threatened
to reveal it unless the government freed
Vivi remember that the alabaster kingdom
is the only one of the original 20
kingdoms that chose to stay on their
Island when the other ones went up to
live on the original plus Alabaster was
guarding a poneglyph so that might mean
that they were somehow related to the
ancient Kingdom as a result it does make
sense to me that Cobra would have some
other secret information that the elders
would want to keep quiet and I don't
know about you all but I'm literally as
excited as Gojo is with a new box as we
get closer to finally learning the the
secrets of the Void century and honestly
this is just another example of the
corruption of the world government which
is the exact ly why the Revolutionary
Army has made it their mission to take
down the celestial dragons and as we see
the revolutionaries are finally moving
forward with their plans because in this
chapter we learned that they declared
war by burning the world government's
flag at marijua just like Luffy did two
years earlier at nslobby Dragon must
have been so proud but unlike my boy
Kakashi these guys are definitely not
being sneaky because there was also a
massive battle between the strongest
fighters of the Revolutionary Army and
two Marine Admirals now we already know
the flame powers of Sabo the gravity
powers of fujitora and the forest
abilities of greenball but this chapter
also revealed more about one of the most
mysterious fruits in the entire story
this guy here is called karasu who can
turn himself into a flock of Krauss and
he can use these crowds like bullets as
he shoots them at fujitora and we even
get an official name for this fruit
which is the Susu susunomi or the soot
fruit so are these even crowds at all or
are crowds Just karasu's Vibe and he's
actually a logia fruit user the giant
okama Morley also shows an impressive
fighting ability when he damaged
greenbull with his Trident and at this
point the revolutionaries are looking
pretty good but everyone is really tough
until the Gravity Man whips out the
ultimate attack which unfortunately we
didn't get to see the end of here and
while this fight didn't result in any
major casualties the whole situation
just continued to pour gas onto the
dumpster fire that is the world
government at the moment because For the
First Time The World Government truly
appears to be losing their grip on the
world kingdoms are rebelling Pirates and
revolutionaries are declaring war
they're even going to lose their
scientific genius Dr vegapunk and not
one but two people Vivi and this guy who
I really hope to never see again have
escaped with knowledge about what really
happened at the reverie and on top of
all that someone is going to find the
one piece very soon which means that the
world government secrets are going to be
spilled but of course they aren't going
to give up without a fight and as with
any evil world power they will surely
become desperate enough to keep their
secrets and powers and who knows maybe
they will finally unleash their ruthless
Fleet Admiral to burn the pirate world
to the ground so if you're an innocent
person living in a world government
Kingdom right now I would seriously
consider finding a deserted island and
hiding until this Epic War is Over
especially because Blackbeard is closer
than ever to finding the one piece and
he's basically guaranteed to be clashing
with either Luffy or Shanks or maybe
both at the same time and if you want to
know how that would go you can watch
that video right here Shanks for
watching